very cerebral quarterback probably the
most cerebral quarterback
that's ever played the game but i i got
a question is
the fact phil that he's turned down a 20
million dollar announcing job for three
years i don't
i forgot we could start thinking about
how cerebral he really is
meanwhile stephen curry hit the fairway
so now it's
peyton manning's turn he'll have the
second shot remember modified
alternate shot you take turns after you
select the best tee shot
yeah peyton's got to worry about steph
being soaked out in that he doesn't want
to
mess up those good opportunities from
152 yards guys
right there
it's a nice little draw oh yeah oh yeah
that's what he does ladies and gentlemen
yeah put a little spin on it too he
flushed it there gary
just slightly down but yours didn't roll
out yours was kind of straight
left on this one too this is for the win
here
got it baby
we'll track this one with top tracer
presented by capital one
i guess it would help to play golf with
the golf ball
peyton's found the fairway he'll be
fighting that that hook
that draw all day long we saw that
forever
third shot from adding and curry
oh yes sir maybe oh man took a peek
he
that's okay we just got to do our job
[Music]
that came off with some steam too far
right it's right of the green but it's
going to be right in front i mean it's a
really nice shot
thanks phil he is just right on the
outside
good correction though for peyton got it
straightened out
all right let's track this one from
peyton manning top tracer presented by
capital one gary payton's got driver
right there he is really consistent the
gulf
golf club is on a nice plane he knows
what it's going to do it's going to hook
and very simple yeah that's why i like
hitting it low because you get the
ground got a safe one out there remember
modified alternate shot so you take the
best tee shot
and then you take turns all the way
through the hole looks like they're on
one right now here's manning now with
driver in hand gary mccord
that's the beauty there that's my
partner right there
full glacier send right down the middle
perfect position
they're going to have a longest shot but
even finally back out on this one
wow solid shot there's like that get up
get up get up nice play right there
stay there stay there
run up and mark it right up in the
market pull this out i pull the fill i
called my shot someone put it on the
right side
cool i remember last match we played
before kind of crushed us actually
got that left for birdie so now big shot
here for peyton manning
this is the third for curry and manning
all right wow
i like the positive reinforcement by
steph's all right all right
peyton manning you're the king of the
fourth quarter comebacks
all-time leader with 43. give me some
comeback mentality right here
well i think we got to make some birdies
uh i think
par we kind of thought was our friend
coming into the round but
after kind of i mean i've never seen
anybody get yelled at for hitting us
not hitting a seven iron on a par five
like phil just yelled at charles back
there for
thinking about hitting a driver no hit
the seven iron so
phil's coaching a lot better than he did
after that first hole and it's working
for him so we're going to have to go and
get it you know
they're not going to play prevent
defense to use a cheesy football analogy
we're going to have to
be aggressive hit some threes throw some
bombs and uh
make some putts in order to come back
from this 28 nothing deficit here
now peyton you were ahead of the game
with this golf collector with this hat
collection
who's in charge of getting you these
hats well yeah like i said i just tried
to mix it up it kind of worked for me
last time last time
kind of wore different uh coveted relief
organizations
and this time wearing different h bcu's
my partner hit here i'm assuming those
are adjustable hats
absolutely with my head size it has to
be adjustable
oh okay i was wondering if you were
self-aware peyton is found
he's got a nice hat collection yeah
besides is this the fourth one for the
day
he's so good yeah he's got the driver
going though yeah he's found a little
rhythm here swings look
good
they need one here that sounds good
yes come on great job keep going
good yeah very nice marks on that floor
one more to go that's peyton is kind of
in steph's way yeah yeah
we are from zen master to hype man he is
propping him up
all right this is a huge one here for
birdie
they'll get two shots out of pot by
peyton manning
okay now the heat is on nice
let's move this uh mark just to the side
of your way count that birdie on the
scramble